hey guys Ryan right over here hi guys
I'm Veronica so Veronica hates horror
movies so I thought I'd bring her off
for the trailer for a horror movie from
the director everyone loves and respects
and night Shyamalan he no one likes a
night ship he used to be great he's done
some great movies in the past so I
always have hope his new movie I think
is with bloom house and it's called the
visit
it's pg-13 but it says this pg-13 for
disturbing thematic out material
including terror violence and some
nudity and for brief language and I did
like the village yeah
everybody else hated it every day it's
my mom my parents asked if their
grandchildren could visit them from week
we are this is where I'm wrong
corrupting ever expect I'm looking for
so long it's not gonna be happy
hmm we're having a great time I have not
seen whenever this happy years bedtime
here is 9:30 it's probably best you two
shouldn't come out of your room after
that say in the war
9:30 9:30
it's 10:47 we think there's someone
outside the door you think Merrill is
not feeling well
grandmother is fine it's like somebody
talking in her sleep
what's he doing
so we read during the day we're just
clean here and eating your dirt there's
something wrong with Nana and Papa
they're just old
are you okay they're hiding it's just
beyond your trench
I said it's all over let's make it
well you need a call right now would you
mind getting inside the oven to clean it
looks scary and funny at the same time
it looks unintentionally funny at the
same time it's their [ __ ]
grandparents what if your grandma and
grandpa went psycho on you it almost
seems like it would be a scary movie
fork in it it seems exactly like what
would be I mean I'm drawn to it strictly
because it looks so stupid sorry dude
I'm sorry I'm not I keep having faith
for you but that does not look like a
good movie anyone could take on their
elders like that
okay I'll [ __ ] insane you are run
away they're not fast enough these are
kids and they could just run away yeah
just don't stab the [ __ ] home any
more if you clearly see something's up
with these guys well maybe it was like
far away from their home link run to the
neighbors oh hi grandma and grandpa are
trying to murder me can I stay here for
a while it's not like they're trapped in
there I don't know I mean I guess it's
kind of a scary what-if plot but at the
same time it's such a goofy what-if plot
and the way it's captured like is it
found footage it does seem like yeah the
kids brought a camera just for fun and
then it ends up being the found footage
if this was r-rated I might be more
appeal to it because then I'd be like
what kind of crazy violence is gonna go
down in this but because it's pg-13 I'm
like these jump scares don't look that
scary the grandma grandpa
it's like yeah they're abusive but I
don't know just it doesn't
I don't know doesn't look bad good I
have a really low tolerance so it might
scare me yeah I mean at first I was like
ooh this could be creepy I thought it
looks like a haunted movie but then you
just see it in your Lego these two
people are just really [ __ ] up well
they have a secret it's said they have a
secret and I want to know what that
secret is I don't really care you know
we had secrets I mean it looks like a
total b-movie but I'm like I would be
drawn to it more if it looked like they
were having fun with it
this looks like he's trying to make it
so scary but it doesn't seem like
there's any self awareness of how goofy
this actually is Oh M night what
happened to you man they listed the four
good movies you've done after that you
guys can go on rotten tomatoes and you
could see the digression of M night
Shyamalan career from The Sixth Sense oh
it's great and then each review starts
getting a little worse and worse what
was wrong with the village a lot of
people like the village that's a kind of
film people thought dunno people thought
the twist was stupid and some people
thought it was kind of boring like
amongst fans but overall most people I
meet tend to like it
I wonder if M nights gonna pull out one
of his great twists in this one anyway
oh yeah I have a reading system I keep
forgetting to do it so the rating system
goes like this going to the theaters and
different variations of that we've heard
on DVD and different variations of that
or not even bother with it I am
definitely going to the theaters to see
just how bad this is yeah yeah because
it's and I Jam Alana when his movies are
bad they're at least like a little
entertaining to me
you [ __ ] kids I wish my grandparents
were here to murder you kids right now I
just showed her the depart of the other
day anyway yeah if you guys are new to
the channel you can subscribe to the
real rejects veronica has a channel too
she does a lot of acoustic covers and
blogs or acoustic covers are awesome
just posted love me like you do you
should check that one out and she's
gonna be working on a little Wayne one
right now actually
you fought on Facebook Instagram and
Twitter because if you follow if we get
enough followers um product placement
and product placement allows me to make
a lot more money for posting a photo
Kalyan James LC hey Ryan
you're straight to the point reviews
crack me up every time and your
reactions are awesome so yeah don't
really know how to finish
congratulations
oh crap thanks Kalyan you're very kind
to say that man yeah my straight
to-the-point reviews are awesome I want
to post them more let's see what you
look like are you a little kid well it's
always the little kids who want to shout
out
it's always the little kids little
handsome guy you look like a little
Norman Bates little Norman Bates over
here I'm not going to show a photo
I'd be concerned for your future my
friend you want to steer away from
horror movies for a while
specifically M night Shyamalan horror
movies because they're gonna influence
you in the wrong way you'll make bad
movies you're watching his folks